my breath months and months took almost
a year to get that bit to work
because it's so dark and
you know such a touchy subject
no pun intended with the kid touching
but
it's so tough that like you had to work
that bit out but you gotta
also factor in that they're terrified
you know so it's tough to get those
jokes to work so you gotta
i almost have to tweak those to
perfection in your apartment
before you can actually get a laugh at
it the joke has to be pitch perfect
before it'll work because the subject
matter is so edgy
how do you get it right in your
apartment alone without an audience
because i still bombed with it you gotta
just suck it up and bomb with it and
just get little bits of information
from the audience every time it bombs
like all right i did a little better if
i say it that way if i say it faster it
does better or if i just lean into it it
got a little bit better and then over
time just with those
little clues i could get it to work 100
but it took a lot of trial and error of
just
guinea pigging that bit over and over
let me try a little this way let me try
it that way let me try that and it took
forever but i finally got it
what makes you continue to pursue a joke
like that
instead of just saying ah it's it's
useless i'll throw it away
everything in your body is like throw it
away you're bombing
you're throwing your whole set off
because this pedophile joke is freaking
people out
but if you believe in it and you run it
by comics that's where comics come in
handy because comics
just see through they don't see the
they see this is a good bit i
like the idea
here they're not just listening to the
you know
oh the buzzword they actually hear the
bit for what it is so i think
you got to use your friends on that one
gotcha
you